but i came across this quote that blew
me away
it's uh by ulysses s grant but i swear
to god if you didn't know any better
you'd
say someone said this yesterday but this
is ulysses s grant
if we are to have another contest in the
near future
of our national existence i predict that
the dividing line will not be mason and
dixon's
but between patriotism and intelligence
on the one side
and superstition ambition and ignorance
on the other that could have been said
yesterday
and he's saying this in the 1870s and it
goes back to this
thing that i sort of wanted to hear you
talk just for a second about which is
we've always been a divided nation but
am i right that many of the things we're
dealing with disinformation
yes it's more potent now but it's
existed before
absolutely everything right in front of
us
always looks like just the worst thing
that this has never happened before you
don't have to go back to
ulysses s grant in the civil war look at
1968
you know bobby kennedy and martin luther
king shot in the same year you got
a democratic convention that is a
complete street fight
street fight you've got a vietnam war
that is ripping the country apart
so so what i always tell young people is
uh if you
if you examine history then you come to
the conclusion that as
terrible as things are the world is
healthier better educated kinder
on average than just about any time in
human history
the problem is we just don't make
progress in a straight line
we have to be vigilant we have to work
hard we have to push
and be resilient that i think is
what i hope i instilled not just in my
daughters and michelle's instilled in
our daughters i i hope that
our our body of work that continues uh
is instilling in young people that sense
of yeah it's hard
you're not gonna get a hundred percent
of what you're hoping for there'll still
be injustice and racism and ignorance
but you can make things better